>>Hillary: Providence is an
old manufacturing community.
A lot of the houses you're gonna
see are really mill worker houses,
which are struggling these days.
>>Narrator: Like many once great
industrial centers, Providence,
Rhode Island, has big problems.
>>Hillary: We have the third highest
child poverty rate in America.
What we're finding is a very high
transiency rate with our students,
because they're moving around
and extremely vulnerable.
>>Narrator: Hillary Salmons and her
colleagues have been doing something
to better the lives of Providence
youth since two thousand and four,
when they created the Providence
After School Alliance, or PASA.
>>Woman: And you can reach
inside and you can pet the cats.
Cats like to be pet like this.
>>Narrator: PASA is a
network of organizations
that delivers high quality after
school programs for middle schoolers,
connecting them to
community resources
in different zones of the city.
Offerings range from
animal care to the arts.
>>Teacher: So guys, you need to
print a different color today.
>>Narrator: From musical
instruments, to scientific ones.
>>Man: This is what we
use to test what's going
on in the water, all right?
>>Narrator: PASA fulfilled
a campaign pledge made
by Providence mayor, David Cicilline.
>>David: It's premised on this simple
idea of really taking responsibility
as a community for children, from
the moment they open their eyes
in the morning, till the
moment they go to bed at night,
and connecting a whole
network of opportunities
and then applying very clear
quality standards to those programs
and collecting good data
so we know what we're doing
and whether it's having an impact.
And the real key part of
this has been partnerships.
>>Hillary: Thinking
about some programming
to bring the arts world in.
>>Narrator: The mayor helped
convene some two hundred partners,
including representatives
from the schools,
police and parks departments,
who came together
to assess their resources and
develop a unified plan for their use.
>>David: We divided the city into
AfterZones, and what they do is,
they connect a middle school and
a public library and a rec center
and create really a campus
of activities for kids,
and a transportation system
so the young people can move
from the rec center to the
library, and ensure that in each
of these places, there are really
enriching, really exciting programs
that are aligned with the work that
young people are doing in school.
>>Hillary: The core ingredient of
an AfterZone is a unified schedule.
Getting all of our YMCAs, Boys and
Girls Clubs, arts organizations,
recs, departments and libraries
to agree to a schedule that runs
from two thirty to five on a four
day basis, and enables us to bring
in providers and sort of
develop a plug and play program.
>>Narrator: After the
logistics were resolved,
PASA hired a social marketing
firm to create a look and feel
that would make the after
school programs more appealing
to urban middle school youth.
And when working with
existing resources,
like a one hundred
year old cafeteria,
the key to cool was
changing attitudes.
>>Alejandro: We don't repaint the
place, we don't change the furniture.
We basically change the vibe, the
way adults treat young people.
Instead of yelling at them
and calling boys and girls,
it's "Hey, how you doing?"
by their name.
>>Ryan Mendoza?
>>Yes.
>>Alejandro: So it's
about customer service,
building that relationship
with young people.
>>Tell me about your day.
>>Narrator: PASA also
provides learning opportunities
that most schools don't,
like this martial arts class.
>>Brian: All right, let's
go over a couple of things.
Number one, guys, girls.
>>There's just something about the
black belt and there's something
about the martial arts,
the mystique of it.
And the younger kids, in the
beginning, relate martial arts
to strength and toughness,
which it has nothing to do with.
>>Okay, does everybody remember
a double back break fall?
>>It's actually the opposite.
You're actually teaching them
to respect the physicalness
and do something with
their frustration,
or do something with their energy.
So that's the thing I instill in
these kids, and the philosophy
on being a better person, you know.
Being a black belt is one thing, but
being a great person is everything.
>>Somebody walk me through this.
What do I do?
>>Hillary: Kids just really
connect when they see a hands
on leader really electrified by what
their passion is, and transferring
that knowledge and skill over to
them, and giving them a sense that,
"I can actually do a roll on a
mat and know how to protect myself
if someone were to throw a punch."
>>Brian: Take it away,
throw it, pit throw, hup!
Perfect.
>>Hector: I've been here,
'cause I can make more friends.
I learn fitness and everything
that happened in school,
I leave it behind, and I just come
here to learn something different,
and to do new things
to protect yourself
in the new world that
they have outside.
>>Brian: Here I am,
my inner strength.
Here's my tiger, right?
>>Teacher: Don't forget, you
roll your ink on your Breyer,
then you roll it as evenly
as you can on your plates.
>>Narrator: The nonprofit
organization, Providence City Arts
for Youth, offers this
print making class.
>>Barbara: We're experiencing
a diminishing amount
of arts opportunities that
are happening in schools,
and so we're seeing an increased
need in the out of school time hours
to really try to provide
those arts opportunities.
>>Teacher: Yes, so there
wasn't any ink on your plate.
>>Barbara: More and more families are
coming to social service agencies,
or coming to us because they
see the value of arts education.
And so people are really reaching
out to programs like City Arts,
so that those opportunities can stay
alive in their child's development.
>>Teacher: Hey, check it out,
that came out so great, Diago.
>>Thank you.
>>What do you think?
>>Banging.
>>Narrator: Children who
live only blocks away
from Narragansett Bay might never
experience being out on the water,
if not for PASA's Explore
the Bay program.
>>Man: All right, so let's
read another number here.
>>Twenty-six point three.
>>Yep.
>>John: I like the program because
I get to learn a lot about the ocean
and the animals that
live inside the ocean.
And I learn more in the after
school than I learn in school.
>>David: You know, we're
not a city where lots
of parents have the resources
to go, you know, hire a teacher
for a violin lesson, or go hire
a tutor for something special.
So if it doesn't happen in
a system that we've built
for them, it won't happen.
>>Man: Don't be afraid
to let the beauty
of the guitar tone
shine through, see?
>>Narrator: PASA carefully
monitors all of its programs
with regular quality
assessments and tracking software
that records attendance trends.
And PASA is proving successful.
Attendance at their
school sites is up,
and Providence kids are choosing
the AfterZones over the streets.
>>Dean: I have three
children in this city.
I've got twenty-six thousand children
too, and they're all my children.
And the same effort and concern
that's put into raising my children
by my wife and I needs to be put
into raising all the
children in this city.
So we keep 'em busy after school.
We keep 'em busy in the summertime.
We keep 'em busy on the weekend.
Works for my children, it
would work for all children.
>>Rudy: One thing I really
enjoy is to hear kids laughing,
kids hearing playing,
hearing kids having fun.
And normally, our main
focus is academics.
Because of our structure, we
don't have time for recess,
we don't have time for breaks.
What the AfterZone provides is an
opportunity for them just to be kids.
>>Hillary: What we're really
trying to do is get kids excited
about coming to school so that they
can participate in the after school,
which is the social emotional
fun stuff, as well as hands
on learning that's relevant.
>>Man: You think anything in
the water uses that oxygen?
>>Yes.
>>Yeah, what in the water uses it?
>>Fish.
>>Hillary: It's really about seeing
the potential to make connections,
seeing assets in your community
everywhere, and having sort
of a can do spirit that there's never
enough that we can do for the kids.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org